how is it having such a passionate fan
base for your audience and did you
experience that with your prior
documentaries do you have these moms
these people that are part of the birth
community either the birth community is
amazing they're super active and I think
part of the reason why they're one of
the whole reason why they've found our
films because they're all fans of mine
amazed I mean it was it was a move that
we didn't realize was so smart but it
was smart because we picked somebody
that people really love and so their
passion for her and for her work and for
for what they've given her you know
translated to our film and so all of
this goodwill that she has was like
transferred to us which was really great
and and so like that helped so much with
it you know international fans and
people from Denmark and Australia and
New Zealand and you know the UK we got a
call from somebody in Antarctica who
wanted to skirt no it wasn't a call with
an email um who wanted to scream the
film they're at a research base all
because she's like she's globally famous
in this particular culture of people I
mean what is it and what is the culture
of people like blue is a man it isn't
about natural birth and every nine
months you know there's a new audience
and and people are always finding out
about her so it we benefit from that we
did a number of community screenings all
over the world right after our premiere
at the LA Film Festival we started doing
community screenings we had it set up so
that people could host a screening
invite people and then those people
would go to Facebook or Twitter or
whatever and talk about the film and we
would collect all of their email
addresses at the screenings and we had
also done a Kickstarter campaign
taneously with the premiere of the film
and it was 45 day Kickstarter campaign
to raise money for finishing funds and
for the distribution of the film which
we knew would probably be a self
distribution model or some sort of
hybrid because the content of the film
is hard to show on television and so we
knew that from the outset that we wanted
to show birth and no matter what that
meant for our distribution so so through
you know building a player on our site
we knew that we could we could get the
film out to people it in our own way so
we wanted people to help us do that
which they did they they it was just
kind of mind-blowing how we had like
1100 backers and people could buy the
DVD even though it wasn't coming out for
many months later but a lot of the the
backers were were pre buying the DVD um
and then the community screenings just
have continued I mean they're still
going and there was one yesterday and
it's it's been amazing there were a
number of them at universities and
people there's just been really good
word-of-mouth and so that's really
helped us and like like Sarah said
there's just this love for inma there's
just love for her books and and people
are full of gratitude for her and
everything that she's done for the last
40 years so there's also i think there's
also even backing it up one more step
there's there's people who have had
incredible powerful birth experiences
are changed by that and families you
know who go through that together men
who see their wives you know have
birthing experiences you know or go
through birth in that layer changed by
it too and and so that is really the
starting point of this path
fashion you know it comes from the
transformative quality of these
experiences and then extends outward to
it ina made for helping to sort of hold
the space for that and and peep and you
know teach people that it's possible and
then you know we also have been the
beneficiaries of it but well I when I
read her book I remember I think we both
looked for a film about her too so there
is this hunk you know it didn't exist
but so we decided to make it but there
is this hunger for this kind of
information so we in some ways lucked
into that you know at this moment in
time there's a hunger for information
about a different way or a different
treatment and and so I think we were
sort of riding the tide of that as well
because and and you know had both been
through that personally so you know it's
nice to have that connection to the
material and also recognize that in the
audience
you